from the Millennium Falcon to a leap on
Airways Japan's largest airliner is
already feeling Star Wars fever the
company will start flying a Boeing 787
Dreamliner with the image of r2d2 on its
Tokyo to Vancouver route this fall
wonder why they chose that one and more
r2d2 Boeing 787s are on the way well
maybe they'll be painted even as
different Star Wars character inside the
plane Star Wars characters will be on
headrest covers napkins and cups so if
you're not a fan good luck I didn't I
didn't realize the global draw of Star
Wars I didn't realize they talking about
I didn't know that everybody that was
like the most restful film media
franchise of all time in America I knew
that actually is that Louis is it the
most successful film franchise of all
time it is one of the most love ya yeah
I think you just dug that out of nowhere
don't believe anything you hear on
television in any case uh no I mean I
figured maybe the Japanese would have
their own their own Star Wars you know
what they're on character anime no I
will say I was an anonymous yeah I was
in Italy Italy recently and I saw a
cruise ship with Bugs Bunny on it look
at if you can make money from licensing
the pinion and Bob Iger is doing
exceptionally well transportation
company that wants to put the image of
your franchise on it why not there was a
was there Lord of the Rings airplane a
painted Lord of the Rings airplane at a
New Zealand because that's where they
shot The Lord of the Rings trilogy which
is like even nerdier than Star Wars I
think there's a nerd ladder [ __ ] you
know and Star Wars is at the bottom
because everybody can like Star Wars if
you're into Lord of the Rings you're
getting into rarefied atmosphere of
nerdom and then if you like like The
Hobbit then that's just going too far
off the scale